salut romain ça va oui savez bien c'est
quoi cette odeur t'aurais pas lâcher un
petit morceau de chair mais que c'était
un peu occupé en ce moment donc je gère
les missions non non non attendez
chauffer mais justement je voulais
expliquer aux gens donc les soins certes
inquiète pas je peux gérer non non c'est
moi qui vais le faire ok oui bah donc tu
me donne ma blouse et puis tu te roma
blues
[Musique]
nous sommes au mois d'avril et vous
savez ce qu'on dit en avril
aujourd'hui vous et moi on va parler
d'avenir
et cela pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que j'ai fait plusieurs conventions ces
derniers temps et vous avez été
plusieurs à me poser la question est ce
que tu as d'autres projets en dehors de
youtube il se trouve que la réponse est
oui je suis même en plein dedans en ce
moment là et deuxième raison ça va un
peu modifier l'activité sur d'été c'est
donc autant vous tenir au courant donc
premières infos pour faire un petit peu
de place à mes autres projets que je
suis en train de développer en ce moment
sur dtc je vais arrêter de parler de
santé parce que vu que c'est déjà de ça
que je vais parler ailleurs ça n'aurait
pas beaucoup de sens de continuer à le
faire aussi ici alors rassurez vous je
vais continuer les vidéos ici juste à la
devenir une chaîne de cuisine diététique
comme ça ça reste un petit peu dans les
conseils santé voilà je vais vous donner
des petites recettes pour vous faire
plaisir tout en restant en bonne santé
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette première
vidéo de dans ta cuisine la chaîne qui
vous apprend à vous même bien tout en
vous portant qu on commence avec un plat
convivial
idéal quand vous recevez par exemple
quelques amis pour un apéritif dînatoire
c'est une recette respectueuse de toutes
et de tous puisque elle convient aux
intolérants au gluten au végal et à tous
les types de régimes alimentaires et en
plus d'être succulent et très original
elle est bon marché est extrêmement
facile à réaliser
c'est la tarte au foot c'est bientôt
vrai j'avais cru genre pendant deux
secondes mais non même pas alors
évidemment je vais continuer à parler de
santé sur d'été fait sinon n'importe
quoi juste au lieu de faire une vidéo
par semaine ça va probablement être une
vidéo toutes les deux semaines pendant
un mois ou deux ne sait pas encore
exactement combien temps juste le temps
de bien finir tous mes autres projets
bon mais alors c'est quoi ces fameux
projet le premier projet il est déjà
sorti c'est une série de tutos fictionné
sur l'éloquence avec na tout ça a été
écrit par slimane bâtisse beyrouth et
vous pouvez trouver ça sur le site de
tv5 monde
je vous remets le lien dans la barre
d'un faux bond le deuxième par contre je
peux pas trop trop vous en parler parce
que c'est un peu plus lointain et à vrai
dire j'ai pas vraiment le droit de vous
en parler et les maîtres je rigole pas
avec ça
voilà donc tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que c'est une web série qui
mélange fiction et vulgarisation
scientifique encore une fois je suis
même pas tellement censé vous en parler
je ne peux pas vous en dire beaucoup
plus parce que même si les tournages
sont terminés c'est le genre de truc
qu'on annonce quand tout est monté que
tout est calé genre la date de diffusion
et c'est donc un petit peu de patience
mais je peux quand même vous dire que ça
devrait être marrant est intéressant à
la fois et que je suis pas tout seul
dans l'histoire
vous devriez même connaître pas mal de
monde là dedans et évidemment dès que
j'ai le feu vert je vous tiens au
courant soit ici soit sur les réseaux
sociaux genre instagram twitter facebook
existe toujours facebook si vous n'êtes
pas encore abonné vous avez tous les
liens pour le faire dans la barre
d'infos
le dernier projet c'est pareil c'est pas
pour tout de suite tout de suite a
priori ça va être une diffusion en
septembre mais on a déjà bien commencé
les tournages
ce projet là c'est aussi le plus
personnel là je ne suis pas avec une
bande de potes comme dans les autres
classes et
bb je suis tout seul alors je suis tout
seul non parce que d'abord tu fais pas
une émission tout seul et puis ensuite
parce que je suis tout seul avec une
personne qui m'invitent le temps d'une
journée et on se balade on discute
il me raconte un petit peu sa vie est
bon je vous spolie pas mais ça va
tourner autour de la santé ok donc j'ai
bien conscience que vous êtes sûrement
en train de vous dire génial le mec nous
annonce des trucs pour septembre et il
prend du repos maintenant n'ont alors
pas tellement que je prend du repos
c'est que ce qui va être diffusé en
septembre
on est en train de le tourner en ce
moment et si je suis en train de tourner
je ne peux pas être en train d'écrire
ddt c'est en même temps et comme je veux
pas faire détester au rabais je préfère
en faire moins mais garder la même
qualité
donc je ne vous abandonne pas on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là mettez vous bien et
surtout portez vous bien rater
[Musique]